al estimar y a la 1.45 usando un
polinomio de taylor centrado en x igual
a 2
cuál es el menor grado del polinomio que
asegura un error menor a 0.001 en
general cuando nos encontramos en una
situación como ésta donde estamos
aproximando a una función con un
polinomio de taylor centrado en algún
valor y queremos saber cuántos términos
del polinomio necesitamos qué grado
necesitamos que tenga este polinomio de
taylor para acotar al error y esa es una
pista muy fuerte de que vamos a usar la
cota del error de lagrange o sea el
teorema del residuo de taylor y ahora
solo como recordatorio aquí tenemos el
teorema del residuo de taylor que nos
dice que el valor absoluto del residuo
del polinomio de taylor de grado n es
menor o igual que esta expresión donde
en esta expresión n es el grado del
polinomio
es el valor donde estamos calculando el
residuo en este caso es 1.45 y si es en
donde está centrado el polinomio de
taylor pero está m de aquí que es bueno
pues se me es una cota superior del
valor absoluto de la derivada n 1 de la
función que estamos tratando de estimar
y esto puede sonar un poco complicado
pero a lo largo de este ejercicio cada
una de estas partes va a quedar un poco
más clara en este ejercicio en
particular estamos tratando de estimar
a la 1.45 en este ejercicio en
particular estamos tratando de estimar a
a la x así es que vamos a describirlo
por aquí
efe de x
a la equis esta es la función que
estamos tratando de estimar y la
queremos estimar en 1.45 y vamos a
empezar encontrando esta cota superior
entonces queremos la n más undécima
derivada de fx pero recordemos que las
derivadas de la x son iguales a la
función la primera derivada de a la x es
a la x la segunda derivada también es
igual a ea la x y así nos seguimos la
enésima derivada también es que a la x
la derivada n 1 en x también es igual a
a a la x lo cual es bastante conveniente
porque estos problemas se vuelven muy
difíciles cuando no es sencillo acotar
la derivada n 1 de la función ahora
nosotros sabemos que es a la x que bueno
por cierto es igual a su valor absoluto
porque era la x es una función positiva
bueno pues sabemos que su valor absoluto
es menor o igual que a la 2 para los
valores de x para los valores de x que
se encuentren entre 0 y 2 la función es
a la x no está acotada para todos los
valores que puede tomar x para todo el
dominio de esta función conforme x se da
a sí infinito ea la x también se va
hacia infinito entonces no la podemos
acotar para todos sus posibles valores
pero si podemos encontrar un intervalo
en el que esta función esté acotada que
contenga a todos los valores de x que
nos interesan o sea el valor que nos
interesa es 1.45 en este caso
también necesitamos que contenga al
valor en el que está centrado nuestro
polinomio de taylor que en este ejemplo
es 2 así es que ya sabemos que en este
intervalo la función era la x está
acotada por el al cuadrado por lo que
podemos usar al cuadrado como esta m de
aquí podemos usar el al cuadrado como m
aquí logramos encontrar una cota para la
derivada n 1 de la función y listo ya
con esto ya podemos ver la cota del
error de lagrange podemos decir que el
valor absoluto del residuo del polinomio
de taylor de grado n que por cierto
nosotros queremos encontrar cuál es la n
que necesitamos
cuál es la n que nos asegura que estamos
agotando suficiente al error pero a ver
aquí tenemos el residuo del polinomio de
taylor de grado n evaluado en 1.45
1.45 y esto va a ser menor o igual que
el valor absoluto de m pero nuestra m es
al cuadrado
al cuadrado entre n 1 factorial
1.45 que es el valor de x que nos
importa es donde estamos tratando de
calcular el error menos el valor donde
se centra nuestro polinomio de taylor o
sea 22 elevado a la potencia n 1
a 1.45 2 esto es menos 0.55 pero de una
vez vamos a escribirlo por acá menos
0.55 y lo que queremos saber es para qué
valor de n esta expresión es menor que
0.001 bueno ya aquí tenemos que hacer un
poquito de manipulación algebraica aquí
estamos tomando el valor absoluto de
este valor por aquí esta parte al
cuadrado es positivo n más 1 factoriales
positivo y menos 0.55 elevado a la n 1
dependiendo del valor de n puede ser
positivo o negativo pero como estamos
sacando el valor absoluto lo que nos
queda es esto nos queda y al cuadrado
por 0.55 elevado a la n-1 entre
n 1 factorial y lo que estamos buscando
es con qué valor de n esta expresión es
menor que 0.001 pero bueno podemos
simplificar esto un poco más porque
estamos buscando los valores de n
entonces podemos dividir entre y al
cuadrado y lo que nos queda es 0.55
elevado a la potencia n 1 entre n 1
factorial menor que 0.001 entre
al cuadrado ahora para jugar con esto
vamos a necesitar una calculadora ahora
lo que vamos a hacer es probar con en es
cada vez más grandes hasta que
encontremos una n que cumpla esta
desigualdad y por cierto queremos
encontrar la n más pequeña que hace que
esta desigualdad sea cierta entonces
sacamos la calculadora
queremos calcular esta expresión 0.001
entre y entre paréntesis queremos poner
a la 2 es igual a esto que tenemos acá
así es que este número si lo redondeamos
nos queda 0.000 136
0.000 136 ok lo que estamos buscando es
una n que haga que esto sea menor que
este número aunque bueno como ésta es
una cota es mejor no redondear es mejor
truncar y nos queda 135 esta expresión
es un poquito más grande que ésta así es
que si encuentro una n que haga que esta
expresión sea menor que cero puntos 0 0
135 ya terminamos porque esto es menor
que esto simplificamos esto a buscar una
n que cumpla que 0.55 elevado a esa n 1
entre n 1 factorial sea menor que este
número bueno empezamos a probar con
algunas en es vamos otra vez por la
calculadora veamos a cuánto es igual
esta expresión cuando n es igual a 2
podríamos empezar con n
a uno en tres en igual a cinco pero sí
en dos es suficiente para que sea menor
a este número
entonces tal vez voy a probar qué pasa
si en es igual a 1 ahora tiene igual a 2
no es suficiente entonces voy a probar
con n igual a 3 ó n igual a 4 entonces
empecemos con bueno no mejor empecemos
con n igual a 3 si n es igual a 3 aquí
en esta expresión tenemos 0.55 elevado a
la 4 entre 4 factorial entonces tenemos
0.55 elevado a la 4 eso es igual a este
número y lo queremos dividir entre 4
factorial
nos queda este número pero no es
suficientemente pequeño para ser menor
que este otro número porque tenemos dos
ceros y un 320 si aquí tenemos otro cero
así es que vamos a probar qué pasa si
ahora n es igual a 4 si n es igual a 4
va a ser esto elevado a las 5 entre 5
factorial entonces tenemos 0.55 elevado
a las 5 y eso lo queremos dividir entre
5 factorial y nos queda en total y ya
casi llegamos porque aquí punto 0 004
sigue siendo mayor que punto 0001 así es
que yo me imagino que con n igual a 5 va
a ser suficiente vamos a verlo
si en es igual a 5 aquí estamos elevando
a las 6 y dividiendo entre 6 factorial
por lo que nos queda 0.55 elevado a las
entre 6 factorial y eso es igual a este
número y este número definitivamente si
es más chico que éste tenemos 0.4 ceros
y luego 384 este número es menor que
este de acá entonces cuando n es igual a
5 el residuo que obtenemos con un
polinomio de taylor de grado 5 es menor
que este número que a su vez es menor
que el número especificado por este
ejercicio
así es que cuál es el menor grado del
polinomio que asegura que el error sea
menor a una milésima bueno pues la
respuesta es 5 100 es igual a 5 el
residuo definitivamente es menor a una
milésima